je vous en prie c'est à vous
restauration rapide à présent
restauration rapide avec cet entretien
que vous a accordée le p dg france de
mcdonald's mcdonald's france dont le
siège est basé à guyancourt d'ailleurs
oui tout à fait jean pierre petit 1 qui
était présent lors de l'inauguration
d'un nouveau restaurant à vélizy 2 un
restaurant laboratoire vous allez le
voir comment la marque doit sans cesse
se renouveler pour faire face à la
concurrence entre garde ensemble
jean pierre petit bonjour vous êtes le
pdg de mcdonald's de france on est ici à
vélizy 2 vous venez d'inaugurer ce
nouveau restaurant 550 m² 300 places
assises c'est un restaurant d'idées à la
famille pourquoi ce choix vous savez
qu'on appelle mcdonald's ce choix de la
famille d'un peu naturelle parce que
nous sommes le restaurant de la famille
depuis très longtemps ce qui est
particulier dans ce restaurant c'est que
nous on fait un restaurant dont
l'aménagement les services sont 100%
dédié à la famille alors qu'en général
nous resterons s'adresse à des cibles
plus varié plus large dont la famille au
travers souvent des rôles à jean clubs
ou des rona landes trouve pour leurs
enfants avec qui les accompagnent le au
delà des produits au delà l'ensemble des
choses que vous connais que vous
connaissez un environnement qui est
partiellement familial quand nouveauté
de ce restaurant c'est le service à
table c'est surprenant alors le service
à table bien entendu parce qu'on voit
très bien qu'ils s'instruisent
correspond parfaitement à une attente à
une préoccupation familiale il ya
d'autres nouveautés dans ce restaurant
il ya tout ce qui nous a aidées
nouvelles technologies que ce soit au
travers des kiosques au travers la
commande par internet qu'elle soit comme
internet à domicile ou internet au
travers de son propre téléphone donc on
voit bien qui a des mouvements au delà
des aires de jeux au delà de la
décoration elle même de l'utilisation de
mystères api de table qui sont des
tables ludique
permet en effet de trouver et l'apporter
au travers de quel que soit l'âge quelle
que soit la relation familiale quelle
que soit la manière dont chacun va vivre
ce moment trouver un des vrais points
d'appui nouveaux originaux qui vont nous
servir du reprises ce restaurant sans
être un restaurant test un peu un
restaurant aussi laboratoire puisque il
est démesurément grand donc nous
n'aurons pas la possibilité de mettre
l'ensemble de ses services dans
l'ensemble de nos restaurants mais on
voit bien que chacun pourra venir chaque
franchisé cinq restaurants venir à venir
jeudi réplique est comme un show même si
peur la partie du jeu qu'il faudra ou la
partie ludique il devra remettre dans
son propre restant sur un marché très
concurrentiel 1 celui de la restauration
rapide c'est par ce genre de produit de
nouveautés qu'on arrive à se démarquer
je pense que c'est une mosaïque c'est
une blague de beaucoup de choses je
pense que le travail par exemple de
nouveautés innovations qu'on a fait que
ce soit au niveau des produits par des
produits qui sont un peu atypique aux
produits traditionnels mcdonald's sondes
étaient des signes de modernité c'était
une manière aussi de travailler pour les
enfants particulièrement sur les sujets
de la nutrition sur lequel nous sommes
très très attendu et avoir des offres
varient variés permettant de trouver
dans encore une fois le bon profil le
bon équilibre nutritionnel par rapport à
qui on est par rapport à l'année au
moment où l'on roule on consomme bien
entendu l'ensemble des services que vous
voyez dans ce restaurant en partie
l'innovation le service à table on fait
partie donc on voit bien qu'il ya là une
volonté de ces entreprises de se
réinventer en permanence parce que au
niveau des entreprises en mouvement et
que mon une clientèle extrêmement
exigeante et donc en permanence avec une
volonté chaque fois de chercher à
trouver un bon équilibre en cette marque
d'origine étrangère d'origine américaine
avec tout ce qu'elle comporte de positif
quelquefois de négatif en tout cas on le
sait on le sait bien en tout cas ça nous
est souvent rappelé mais aussi une
volonté de forte intégration mcdonald's
a signé récemment un accord avec pôle
emploi de quelle teneur
notre accord avec pôle emploi est un
accord de moyens à ce qu'un important
c'est souligner c'est que mcdonald's
c'est un faux recruteurs en france est
aujourd'hui dans la période que l'on vit
il faut le souligner puisque nous
recrutons en contrat à durée
indéterminée en est net c'est-à-dire
emploi complet trois mille emplois par
an grâce essentiellement au
développement de l'enseignent que ce
soit par les ventes comparables à
périmètre comparable ou bien parler par
les ouvertures techniques de recrutement
bien particulière alors que martin qui
recrutent et qui travaille beaucoup plus
sûr je dirais la qualité la performance
des gens face à des situations réelles
plutôt que d'avoir rudement qui va se
baser plus sur le diplôme
d'autres critères plus plus subjectif je
pense que nous sommes dans le concret et
c'est vrai que des recrutements qui vont
privilégier l'efficacité la relation
sont plus en ligne avec les besoins de
notre clientèle oui on peut réellement
faire carrière maintenant chez
mcdonald's c'est vrai que peut-être
avant on avait l'image du job étudiant
alors on peut faire carrière chez
mcdonald's à la fois parce que d'abord
on progresse vite et aujourd'hui c'est
toujours intéressant de citer de 80%
partiquement de notre encadrement sont
des gens qui ont commencé quand des jobs
étudiants emplois à temps partiel
ce sont des jobs qui sont vite bien payé
on parle souvent d'être mal payé c'est
inexact on les pays en compte entre
swing mais l'idée du smic c'est pas le
smic est un problème si on y reste
longtemps à partir du moment où au bout
de quelques mois vous pouvez sortir du
smig et que vous avez des opportunités
d'évolution de carrière c'est important
et sans rentrer dans le détail c'est
vrai que les programmes que ce soit la
valorisation des acquis d'expérience que
ce soit les programmes de formation on
est une entreprise très orienté sur ces
sujets là et je crois qu'en permanence
qu'il faut faire attention que le
quantitatif qui est important mais ne
soit pas éloigné du qualitatif et que la
manière dont va faire progresser des
gens qui peut-être n'ont pas pris comme
on dit le train de la première chance
vont le prendre chez nous allègrement
sur la deuxième chance et c'est vrai que
c'est un élément extrêmement important
de la manière dont on bâtit l'entreprise
nous sommes aujourd'hui sûrement l'un
des tout premiers recruteurs de chaînes
en france on a recruté 40 2040 2000 et
quelques chaque année on est sûr sur le
jet du taur du turn over
du changement mais ce qui montre bien
avec en tout cas que c'est au travers de
ses 40 2000 que se forme l'encadrement
de notre société d'aujourd'hui demain
merci beaucoup jean pierre petit merci
et jean pierre petit a évoqué un lors de
son discours d'inauguration son envie de
voir le restaurant ouvert même le
dimanche chose pour l'instant impossible
parce que vélizy 2 n'est situer ni dans
une zone touristique ni dans un puce
qu'est ce qu'un plus un périmètre
d'usagé de consommation
exceptionnel général en situer aux
environs des grandes agglomérations et
c'est bricorama qui brille qui bravent
la justice pour ouvrir ses magasins le
dimanche c'est l'info en plus de cette
chronique échos bonsoir paulo d'ovale
oui bonjour vous êtes directeur du
magasin bricorama à montigny le
bretonneux bricorama qui a dû donc fermé
le dimanche suite à une décision de
justice est ce que c'est un vrai manque
à gagner pour vous
c'est un gros manque à gagner pour moi
personnellement qui représente l'année
le dimanche et dans la communauté des
vies nous avons des vagues allant seul à
faire
quelle a été la réaction des clients
parce que dans votre magasin vous fait
signer une pétition qu'on voit à l'écran
r
nous avons une pétition à l'entrée du
magasin pour tous les clients qui
veulent nous soutenir et nous avons
quelque peu près 4 des
qualifications par l'odorat laisse que
le magasin aujourd'hui la pérennité du
du magasin est remise en cause vous
imaginez fermé avec cette perte de
chiffre d'affaires que vous avez estimé
autour de 10% sur votre magasin
va pas jusqu'à fermer nous avons pas
fait forcément à revoir votre structure
au niveau du personnel ça me donne des
mises en ciment - d'embûches en tout cas
pour le ne serait ce que par les traités
ont été violés fait est sûr et après la
pluie il a fallu revoir après le la
restructuration du magasin afin de
combler les pertes mais qu'elle
accueille alors parlé par les salariés
justement comment ils ont réagi à cette
mesure ce qu'on parlait de la pétition
pour
les visiteurs du magasin les clients à
la signer mais du côté des salariés de
l'entreprise
les fans et les entreprises est avec
nous forcément il est contre cette
décision que
le dimanche au fait ils font payer
double et ils ont une journée de
récupération en plus on pourrait essayer
sur la base du volontariat donc pour eux
c'est un vrai manque à gagner également
sur leur fiche de paye
enfin cette semaine le tribunal de
grande instance de pontoise a débouté la
à la plainte du syndicat force ouvrière
qui réclamait près de 37 millions
d'euros de réparations à bricorama pour
n'avoir pas respecté la décision de
justice de ne pas ouvrir le dimanche est
ce que c'est un soulagement pour vous
cette décision de justice
forcément on a pris pas avec avec un
grand plaisir on était on était vraiment
lire et des filion pour pouvoir faire
des
jeux
dans l'oval que le mât perdu ou en ligne
voilà
la boucle électeurs pour information
complémentaire en suite à la décision de
justice de fermer le dimanche bricorama
assigné en justice deux autres magasins
de bricolage leroy merlin et castorama
l'ouverture dominicale un dossier qui
sera retrouvée dans le prochain filet
co2 2011-2013 en 2013 on va passer une
année plutôt carole années en arrière ça
sera mieux et on espère qu'on aura
retrouvé vers l'aude au val le directeur
de l'écho ahmad de
montigny-le-bretonneux d'ici là pour
continuer est ce témoignage deux autres
informations dans cette chronique et
coup la première concerne le grand paris
louis alors des chefs d'entreprise des
yvelines du val de marne et de l'essonne
ont alerté le gouvernement quant aux
conséquences que pourrait avoir le
report voire l'abandon du grand paris
ils soutiennent notamment la boucle
verte dans cette fameuse boucle verte
qui devrait relier l'aéroport d'orly à
la défense en passant par le plateau de
saclay et versailles cet appel a été
lancé par les chambres de commerce des
départements concernés et puis un autre
projet le peuple peuple moment vous
prononcer sa pme le pm up assez normal
c'est moi faire compliqué je sais rien
voilà donc c'est un appel à projet en se
jetant pour soutenir les pme et pmi
franciliennes à fort potentiel dans les
secteurs notamment d' mobilité durable
de la santé des éco activités et des
technologies de l'information et de la
communication l'éthique c'est les
subventions peuvent aller de 13500 à
250000 euros donc c'est quand même assez
qu'on serait conséquent c'est un il faut
bon pour être éligible en présenter un
plan concret de son développement comme
le lancement d'un nouveau produit se
tourner vers l'export ou encore ciblé un
nouveau marché les conditions
d'éligibilité soit retrouvée à l'adresse
donc qui vient de s'afficher pour plus
d'informations et puis la toute dernière
information un peu d'auto promo ça ne
fait pas de mal le dernier fait l'écho
de l'année voilà comme toutes les
quinzaines on retrouve le dernier fit
l'écho donc ce vendredi à 20h30 il est
dédié à l'aéronautique dans les yvelines
avec la visite exclusive du site
d'astrium aux mureaux c'est là qu'est
fabriqué la majeure partie de la fusée
ariane donc voilà pour les les amateurs
d'espacé merci alice prochain point eco
dans le 7 8 ce sera le jeudi 3 janvier à
la même heure puisque la semaine
prochaine je vous le rappelle une série
d'éditions spéciales seront à retrouver
une série sera retrouvée pour tout
savoir des principaux événements de 2012
et puissent eux attendre également 2013
une de ces émissions sera consacrée à
l'économie d'ailleurs à l'isf on se
retrouvera à cette occasion solidarité
avant de découvrir dans un instant le
court métrage harry avec son réalisateur
dans le cadre de l'opération tous en
fête une journée d'action solidaire a
été organisée au château de versailles
au profit de 300 bénéficiaires de la
croix rouge ils ont pu assister à une
représentation théâtrale dans la galerie
des batailles et surtout suivre la
visite des grands appartements du roi et
de la reine ainsi que la fameuse
incontournable galerie des glaces
la bataille de cassel de 13 128
immortalisé lors d'une visite singulière
dans le cadre de l'opération tous en
fête la fondation française des jeux et
la croix-rouge organisaient mercredi une
journée d'action solidaire au château de
versailles
315 personnes s'étaient vu réserver la
galerie des batailles le temps d'une
représentation théâtrale
mais intéressant parce que c'est pas
seulement vos châteaux et ça je pense
que ça fait bien ça va être la fête même
s'il pleut dehors ça mais je suis venu
tout petit donc ça fait plaisir de
revenir je crois que c'est très
enrichissant et de faire tout ça après
des périodes de soleil chaud ça assez
festive où enfants et adultes s'étaient
inscrits dans les diverses antennes de
la croix-rouge d'ile-de-france et de la
manche pour ce spectacle au programme
goûter visite de la galerie des glaces
et des grands appartements du roi et de
la reine l'avantagé de cette opération
tout en fait c'est qu'il réunit tous les
publics bénéficiaires de la croix rouge
c'est à la fois effectivement des
familles qui sont dans des situations
difficiles ça peut être des personnes
âgées des personnes en situation
d'handicap le château de versailles qui
souhaite ouvrir ses portes à tous les
publics inaugurera bientôt un ascenseur
pour les personnes handicapées et
multiplie ce type de manifestation c'est
la troisième opération de ce type que
nous faisons avec la fondation de la
française des jeux dans l'année nous
avons accueilli une visite organisée par
emmaüs une autre visite dans le cadre
des journées contre l'autre pour la
prévention l'autisme et bien nous
essayons de jalonné notre année avec des
manifestations de ce type des
manifestations de solidarité
de son côté la croix rouge française
organise chaque année 300 événements en
france du 1er décembre au 15 janvier
environ 50000 personnes bénéficient de
ces actions